more news Kathy Griffin you know
everybody knows this the bloody hedge
held up I'm gonna say this I and some
people think like by even talking about
it you're giving you you know you're
creating publicity for her I'm not
creating publicity for Kathy Griffin
she's the only person comedian that I VI
that I've ever gone to their show a full
hour and I didn't laugh that's a true
story
this is about seven years ago I win or
eight could have been eight years ago I
didn't laugh at all she's not for me
her type of comedy I get it but I
thought that this was just hack you know
I thought it was just you know you're
holding up a bloody head of the
president get a life you know you've
made your money in this country and show
some gratitude you don't have to show it
to Donald Trump but you show it to the
fact that that's the president for right
now you know that to the president is
you know and I don't care who it is I
think that as an American you have some
responsibility to at least just go along
with it and I just think she could have
come up with something much better or
funnier to me she's not funny and to me
I just thought that that was unamerican
that's kind of a feeling that it left me
with you know and I'm kind of just sick
of all the Trump I'm just I think the
Trump jokes are just hack it's like we
get it like you don't like him okay
great you know I mean I voted for Obama
twice I wasn't a huge Obama fan you know
but I was inspired by what he was
talking about I think Obama did some
good I think he was a great example I
also think Obama was kind of a [__]
when it came to a lot of stuff to be
honest sorry to use that language I felt
like he didn't really have any balls you
know I don't think he did a lot to
inspire black America for me that's just
my perspective you're like well Theo
you're you're not black you're right I'm
not but I can still have a point of view
a lot of my black friends have felt the
same way I think he's a great speaker I
think he's a great orator I think he
sounded amazing no doubt he looked good
in pictures beautiful family beautiful
daughters
probably a great hoopster but to me he
was all talk he was more of a celebrity
than he was a man I would look at him as
more of a celebrity than a would as a
man
so under the Kathy Griffin thing I just
didn't laugh you know it wasn't funny to
me I think she's more of a loudmouth
uh-uh
and maybe she was a comedian at a time
but I've never seen her in a comedy club
never seen her in any comedy club
anywhere except for the one time I went
saw at a theater and and part of that so
I'm just sick of the unamerican attitude
like like people saying that oh this
country doesn't represent me and stuff
like that like maybe I'm old-fashioned
or something you know but like I feel a
hold on the air-conditioners came on I
gotta set it off alright I'm back but I
feel like if you live in the country you
cash your checks here didn't have some
gratitude you know have some freaking
gratitude you know if you don't like
what's going on then find some ways to
change it be part of the solution you
know shut the [__] up and contribute
alright you don't have to make it bet
you're not gonna make it better by
acting like you're not part of this
country if you don't to be part of the
country than go go out for a few years
and come back nobody's doing that you
see what I'm saying
everybody's anti America but they're not
leaving here so it just kind of makes me
upset you know and you can say well Theo
you're naive you know you still believe
in some type of an American ideal or
American Dream you know I don't know how
clearly I feel on some of that but I do
feel like we're fortunate enough to live
here we're blessed to live in this
country we should act like it we should
act like it you know and if something we
don't like find a more constructive way
than just by sheer hatred you know I
just don't get it well thanks for
watching that video right there that was
a beautiful little segment I think
but of course I'm partisan to myself but
you can move on to another video right
now you could check on this video or on
this video that's two different options
and you can also subscribe to the
channel check on a new video subscribe
to the channel check subscribe share
subscribe